su último adiós desde el número 10 de
Downey Street como es habitual de Boris
Johnson no ofreció disculpas ni mea
culpas sino que incluyó una lista de sus
logros como Primer Ministro
estoy orgulloso de haber cumplido las
promesas que hice mi partido cuando
tuvieron la amabilidad de elegirme
obteniendo la mayor mayoría desde 1987
el mayor porcentaje de votos desde 1979
cumpliendo con el brexit cumpliendo con
el compromiso de nuestro manifiesto
Este es el fin de los tres años de
mandato de Johnson que se vio obligado a
abandonar el cargo por su propio partido
conservador a causa de una serie de
escándalos como la celebración de
fiestas durante las estrictas
cuarentenas británicas en medio del pico
de contagios por Kobe 19 en su discurso
instó a su partido y al país a unirse en
torno a Liz Ross la nueva primera
ministra pero Trust tiene mucho trabajo
por delante una reciente encuesta de
ugoff reveló que solo el 14% de los
británicos espera que Trust haga un
mejor trabajo que Johnson
[Aplausos]
permítanme decir que ahora soy como uno
de esos cohetes propulsores que han
cumplido su función y que ahora volveré
a entrar gentilmente en la atmósfera y a
chapotear invisiblemente en algún remoto
y oscuro Rincón del Pacífico
como cincinnatus vuelvo a mi arado y no
ofreceré a este gobierno más que el más
ferviente apoyo
Aunque Johnson no ha expuesto
públicamente sus próximos pasos se sigue
especulando con que podría estar
esperando su momento para un posible
regreso al compararse con el estadista
Romano cincinnatus que salió de su
retiro para dirigir Roma durante un
segundo mandato Johnson podría estar
señalando su deseo de volver a ocupar el
número 10 de dow